okay so um we are starting an overview
of Greek history we remember the story
so far U we talked about the bronch
age um and where m in gree um was
trading and fighting with the rest of
the world and then the Bronze Age
collapse happen and Myan gree came to an
end and because of its destruction this
allowed for massive innovation
throughout Greece so we saw the
introduction of the polus the city state
okay um we saw the beginning of the use
of the alphabet and so literacy rates
increased radically uh throughout uh
Greece and we saw Homer uh who gave us
the Iliad and the
Odyssey um so today I'm just going to go
over um the overview of um Greek history
mainly focusing on the pois okay um so
one thing to understand about the pois
is that
geography is Destiny Okay
geography is Destiny and this basically
means that the your geography will
determine the culture the economy and
the political
structure of your Society and we see
that um with the Greek polus uh the
Greek geography is very diverse there
are mountains there are rivers there are
Plains and there are coastlines okay and
this and depending on where you are
geographically in Greece you will have a
different type of polus and so the two
classic examples are Sparta and Athens
uh spart and Athens are the two most
dominant polist in about the year 5 00
BC
okay so let's first talk about
Sparta so Sparta is
located on the
peles uh this is
Sparta and the land around Sparta it's
basically Plains which makes it makes it
ideal for
agriculture okay so for most of its
history spart Sparta was an
agricultural uh Nation
and
because
it uh is ideal for agriculture it needs
people to work the land and through its
um Conquest Sparta developed a slave
system okay and these people are call
helots and helots are just
slaves um in Sparta that work the land
they're farmers and these are people who
have been conquered by
Sparta and because there are so many
Hots okay the ratio is about 10 to one
so for every one hot sorry for every one
Spartan there's 10 Hots Spartan had to
become a military Society in order to
control the
hots so it created um an education
education system in order to train its
citizens to be soldiers so so the system
worked like this um about age s about
age s you left your family and you were
put into a boarding school where you
watched over by kids who are older than
you okay maybe 11 or 12 and obviously
you put young kids with older kids the
older kids will beat the crap out of
these young kids who are about seven
seven or eight and this instills the
idea of emotional discipline into the
children now when these children became
teenagers they were peered with a mentor
who was maybe 25 to about 30 okay an
older adult and they became
lovers um the sparts do not consider
this homosexuality we would consider it
homosexuality but they themselves do not
consider this homosexuality okay they
just considered this as a way to build
emotional
cohesion uh love among its
soldiers and about age 18 or 19 the
students would
graduate and they would go on to marry
and have their own families but the
Spartan soldiers were all required to
eat together okay so the soldiers even
though they had families they were still
required to train together and to eat
together Spartan Spartan had no private
property everything including the hots
belong to everyone okay so it's
basically communism or Proto communism
they had no money system they had no
wealth everything belonged to uh
everyone and it was a brutal State okay
the spaans were notorious for being
brutal people so an example is uh the
hots so they had a they had a campaign
of Terror to maintain control over the
hots so um young soldiers would often be
required to uh Patrol at night okay they
would they would maybe lie in the field
because now and then some Hots would
break curfew they would at midnight try
to sneak out and have some fun and and
if you as a spawning young man saw a
hellot be uh out at night well they
would kill you they would take on a
knife and stab you in the neck okay and
this was meant to instill Terror in the
hots to prevent them from rebelling okay
but the the problem is because there
were so many Hots and the SP were so
brutal rebellions and revolutions would
break out often okay so this created a
society um which focus on maintaining
control in the pelan so the spars were
not at all
interested in foreign policy okay they
had Absol no interest in a in the world
outside Sparta the for were were as a
culture was very conservative okay they
liked the way that F they liked the
way they wanted things to stay the
way uh they they are okay um so it was a
very conformist
culture now and then you had some
Kings um or individuals who tried to
change society and the Spartans would
kill those people okay you were not
allowed owed to
question uh Authority you were not
allowed to promote change in Sparta the
Spartans were also isolationists
okay their entire policy was if you
leave us alone we'll leave you
alone okay and so that was the um
Society of Sparta if you think about it
in many ways it's very much like China
throughout its history okay so the
analogy is China which China has always
been throughout the his its history very
conservative and very isolationist China
is just not interested in the outside
world why because it's focused on
maintaining control
over um its peasantry okay there's too
much internal chaos China just is not
interested in the outside world so China
for its history has both both been
conservative does not like change okay
and very isolationist is that concern
about the outside world does that make
sense guys any questions so far about
Sparta before I move on to
Athens okay so Athens was a completely
opposite Society to Sparta and the
reason why again it's geography this is
Sparta sorry this is Athens and Athens
is in Attica um and it's by the coast
and Athens the country side is very
hilly so it's bad for growing crops but
aens has two major advantages the first
major advantage is it has a very good
Harbor okay and also it's um it's Healy
but the Healy terrain is actually good
for growing olive trees okay
olives um it's it's also very good at
Pottery so because of this Athens for
most of its history focus on trade right
it was a trading
nation and because they are Traders and
Merchants they have a very different
culture to the uh Spartans okay so the
first thing is they're very expansionist
okay they're
aggressive and the idea here is the ath
will go and seek out new markets they
also uh plant new colonies throughout
the
uh a aan this is to the West is the aan
sea to the South is
the Mediterranean okay and they will
plant
colonies um throughout this
area um and they have to encourage their
citizens to go out and explore the world
in order to find new markets in order to
get to bring goods and ideas back to um
Athens
okay um because Athens was
expansionist its cultural system its
cultural beliefs was very different from
the Spartans okay so whereas the
Spartans were very conservative the uh
Athenians had a policy had a belief in
the idea of
udonia udonia so
udonia is a Greek word and it means
human
flourishing
flourishing and the idea idea here is to
be the best that you can be all right so
the example of udonia the most famous
example of udonia is this in Homer's
Iliad the main character is Achilles and
achilles is the best
warrior uh of the Greeks against
Troy and achilles says this in the book
he says before I came to Troy I saw a
prophet I saw a fortune teller and he
told me my fortune he said I could
choose to not come to Troy and live to
be a live a very long healthy life but
I'd be a
nobody if I came to Troy I would die
young but I would die as a hero I would
be
remembered by
everyone everyone would sing of my glory
and my Triumph so that was my choice I
could live forther a long time and just
be a nobody or I could be a hero and die
young and he said well for me that's not
a
choice okay for me to be alive means to
achieve udonia I have to be the best I
can be and therefore my only option is
to come to Troy and die a
hero and that's the mentality in Athens
it is much better to die young as a hero
to than to live a long time as a nobody
whereas in Spartans were the complete
opposite okay it's just better to be a
nobody uh and get along with everyone
than it is to die as a hero okay so very
so very opposite
societies um but and what this did this
idea of udonia it made Athens into a
very
competitive Society okay because if
everyone's trying to achieve
yonia then you're going to have a lot of
competition okay because they they're
going to be one hero everyone cannot be
a hero there can only be one hero so
again the example is um Homer's Iliad
and when Achilles got into a fight with
egam Menon okay Achilles basically says
I don't like you you're a dog I'm not
going to fight for you again says I
don't need you what Achilles did was he
went to his mother who was a goddess and
achilles said to thetus um his his
mother could you please get the gods to
help the
Trojans
so that eanon would have to come beg for
my help again against the Trojans okay
he was basically committing
treason and in the Greek world you're
allowed to do that because the most
important thing is udonia to achieve
yonia okay does that make sense it's a
very weird world but in Athens it's
extremely competitive where everyone's
trying to backstab each other in order
to become the hero and because of this
because there so much competition Athens
created a new system called OST
ostracized okay so the idea here is
because the Athenians were so at each
other's throat
if someone was breaking the rules or if
someone was being too competitive in the
pursuit of yonia the Athenian people
could choose to ostracize this person
and what this meant was you be
banished okay banished or
exiled from Athens for 10 years and this
was considered even worse than death
okay this punishment was worse than
death the reason why is in the PO system
the only people that matter were
citizens okay and the Greek world was
very chauvinistic or close which meant
that you could not be you you could not
earn the right to be a citizen you had
to be born to become a citizen you
understand you have to be born into
into citizenship you cannot become a
citizen for your own hard work and for
your Merit okay does that make sense so
in other words if you were banished from
your polish you became a nobody you were
basically dead to everyone because only
citizens had rights in the Greek world
if you were a slave or you were a
foreigner you had absolutely no right
you could not own land you could not
even speak in public okay does that make
sense all
right
um
so Athens was a
democracy where everyone had the right
to speak and to vote okay but really
when we talk about democracy in this
world we're not saying that everyone
could become president or everyone could
become a leader really political power
can only be held by people
of um nobility okay so democracy
democracy usually was a battle between
different factions of the nobility
usually between the upper nobility
and then lower
nobility okay and this is a lesson
that's true throughout history okay so
remember usually we think history
societies um the conflict is between the
halves and the half Nots right the poor
and the rich all right
halves versus half
Nots what I would teach you in this
class one important thing I would teach
you in this class is this is not true
okay if you look at history the
conflicts in society are usually between
the half a lot and have somewhat more
does that make sense okay it's usually
between the half a lot versus the half
sum but I want more okay and throughout
history we call these people different
names
so um in this Society these are
basically the low nobility okay these
are PE the nobility who have money but
they want more okay and um in the French
Revolution we will call them the petite
B and today we call them the middle
class okay does that make sense the poor
people do not Rebel they might Riot but
they do not Revolt It's usually the
middle class or the lower nobility or
the P petite B that re VT does that make
sense all right so aens is a democracy
and it's usually conflict between the
upper nobility and the low low
nobility um Sparta is anarchy
okay which is basically means rule by
the few and they hate democracy so so
these systems these cultures Spartan
aens are diametrically opposed to each
other they hate each other uh they're
always in conflict with each other okay
does that make sense any questions so
far about Spartan and
Athens are you guys clear about this
these two different cultures all right
so this is about the year 500
BC um around this time the Greeks are
colonizing uh the Mediterranean and the
agan okay and this territory belongs to
Persia
the Persian Empire is considered one of
the greatest Empires ever in human
history we will do the Persian Empire uh
later this semester okay but I want to
focus on the Greeks for now all you need
to know is the Persian Empire spread
throughout most of the world including
Egypt uh
Mesopotamia um and what we call Iran
today okay it was a huge huge Empire
that was extremely enlightened for its
age okay it was really considered um the
best Empire at that
time um and there were Greeks who lived
in U Anatolia or what they call Asia
Minor back then the thing about the
Persian Empire is if you were a subject
City you could do whatever you want but
you have to pay taxes and these people
did not like to pay taxes so they
revolted and in their Revolt they went
to Sparta and to Athens and S thought
help okay they basically said look we're
all Greeks uh we're being oppressed by
the Persians could you please help us
what did the Spartans
say what was the Spartan
response no because we don't care okay
your problem not my problem what and
what Did the Athenians
say yeah sure let's achieve udonia man
let's be Achilles let's go over and help
them and maybe make a lot of money for
ourselves okay so because of Persian
Empire were so powerful they destroyed
the Rebellion okay and in
BC uh the Persians decided to attack
Greece to teach the Athenians a lesson
and this was called the Battle of
Marathon and in the Battle of Marathon
um we actually don't know that much
about it okay the sourcing is very
limited but what they say okay is in the
Battle of Marathon there about 10,000
Ians versus
25,000 Persians that's a huge Advantage
for the Persians right
well the Athenians destroyed the
Persians okay the Athenians lost about
192 men the Persians lost about 5,000 it
was a Slaughter and a lot of the reason
why is in military tactics so the
Persian Empire is huge okay lots of flat
land
and in this geography the your main
advantage is Cavalry right horse archers
that's what the PES were known for men
on horses who would run around and shoot
arrows at you okay the geography of
Greece was different it was hilly so you
didn't really use calry it was more
mainly infantry fighting against each
other and what the Greeks did over
hundred hundreds of years was develop a
new military tactic called HPP
lights hopl lights so hoplight comes
from the word hoplin hoplin is Greek for
shield so these are men with large
Shields and Spears okay the way they
fought was using the phing formation
phic and the innovation of the phic um
Innovation was it was basically a wall
okay so men would stand
together and behind each other so that
they made a wall and because have the
shield and Spears it was a moving
wall okay and the Persians didn't have
armor so when men of armor went to
battle with with men without armor
usually armor wins okay so the Greeks
the Athenians destroyed the Persians at
the Battle of
Marathon that made the Persians even
more Angry okay so in about 480
BCE Persia organized a massive Invasion
Force against Greece and this massive in
invation force again um the numbers the
data we can't confirm it but we think
it's it's about half a million people
half a million soldiers that's huge okay
but not only that you had a huge
navy and basically um
Persia called on every nation of its
Empire to fight against Greece which
included Egypt okay which included the
Phoenicians which also included Greeks
who lived in the
territory of Persia okay and these
Greeks are called the ionian uh Greeks
okay so was a massive Invasion force and
Sparta and Athens became allies to
resist the Persian Invasion but there
were also some Greek Poes that sided
with uh the Persians including uh
thieves okay the macedonians to the
north was
also siding with the Persians so The
Invasion came North from Macedonia down
here and um you may have heard of the
battle of thermop pil okay the thermop
P um this was made famous by a movie
called 300 I'm not sure have you seen
the movie 300 okay but basically it was
about 300 Spartans uh and about 5,000
other Greeks who tried to make a stand
against the Persian Invasion and they
got destroyed okay they so the Spartan
so so the Persians came in and the
Greeks decided okay you know what uh
their numbers are so much bigger than
ours let's Retreat okay back to Sparta
and here at cor they decided to build a
wall to stop the uh Persian events the
problem though is Athens is here okay so
the Persians came in and burned down
Athens now what's important to
understand is the Greeks have the the
concept of aus it's not a place it's a
community okay Aus is wherever the
Greeks choose to be so what happened
that's very interesting is even though
the Athens came destroyed sorry even
though Persia came to destroy Athens the
Athenians just got into their ships okay
they just boarded their ships because
Athens is a naval power and they just
are sailed away okay do you understand
so Athens was not destroyed the city of
Athens was destroyed but not the
community the polus of Athens and so um
but now the Greeks are in a lot of
trouble okay because the what the
Persians can now do is
um
basically take their ships and saell
around and attack Sparta from behind
this is a huge problem for
Sparta because why what is Sparta's
ultimate
weakness why is it so easy easy to
defeat Sparta in a war what's the
problem do you guys
remember what are what are the spers
really afraid
of the helots right
okay the hots remember there's 10 hots
for everyone Spartan and the hots hate
the Spartans because the Spartans are
terrorizing have terrorized them for
centuries so all that person has to do
now okay very easy is take their ships
land and Sparta and build forts defenses
and the HS would run into run to them
then the king K King xeres of Persia
says I the benedic King of Persia
declare the H to be free people now now
you have a revolution okay the helots
now are now armed by the Persians and
then guess what the Persians are going
to the hels are going to go kill the
Spartans game over okay you understand
the war is over that's all the pers have
to do take their ships sell around to
the coast of Sparta build forts and
defenses so the hel can run to them give
the helot weapons and then let the hots
run loose against the Spartans and the
war is over Greece is forever destroyed
okay you understand very simple
right the Persians did not do that okay
the Persian king King Xerxes had a war
council and there were a lot of gen
generals who who said to King
Xerxes King we've won the war okay we're
over Greece we have half Milli men in
Greece there's nothing the Greeks can do
about this okay so the pers were feeling
very confident and the Greeks uh the
Greek navy
was on an island called salamis okay
salamis and everyone was freaking out
okay and what the Spartans wanted to do
was say let's take go Navy and defend
the coastline of
Sparta because we know the persons are
going to invade Sparta at some point
they're going to land their ships on
Sparta let's s our
Navy and
defend um Sparta there's one Athan
General okay his name is
f f
f and he said you know what that's great
for you guys okay but remember our city
Athens has been destroyed we need to
take on the Persians head on we can't
wait and the Spartans are like yeah
that's fine but they outnumber us three
to one they have three more ships they
have three ships for every one ship we
have there's no way we can beat them in
a naval battle and F he says we either
fight the Persians now and Achieve
udonia or we Athens we'll be like screw
you Spartans we're going to go take our
ships and sell
off West to Sicily
or Africa who cares okay but we're going
to go away and we're going to leave the
Persians to kill you guys okay so spart
saying that we have a choice but to
listen to Athenians and
fight then what from mexic did was he
sent a spy to King Xerxes and King
Xerxes was having this war council about
what to do and most of his generals were
like my great king we've won the war
let's just take our ships and attack
spart and the war is over okay then a
spy set by fames says to king xeres oh
great king the entire Greek navy is
stuck in salamis but they're but they
want they want to run away now should
chance to attack them and destroy the
Greek navy once and for all okay and at
this point King xeres made the decision
to send his entire Navy okay to destroy
the greatek Navy at salamis and his
generals were like don't do that man
that's a risk you don't have to take why
do that why take the Greeks on why why F
fight the
Greeks um head on when we can just star
them out and King said no I I came to
defeat the Greeks okay I'm the great
king I want to defeat the bamus and
build a monument to celebrate my great
victory over the Greeks my father King
Darius set an Army in 490 BC and the
Athenians killed or destroyed his army
at Marathon I'm going to prove I'm a
greater King than my father by defeating
the Greeks at salamis okay I don't want
this war of attrition the L War I want
one great battle so that history will
remember me forever okay so he sends his
entire force about a thousand ships to
salamis and salamis it's it's a straight
okay it's very narrow so the ships have
to line up and attack the Greeks one by
one
okay and and Salam Miss and a headlong
battle okay the Greek ships were heavier
and the Greek ships were maned by
pooplets with armor and in this Battle
of Salamis the Greeks
destroyed the Persian navy okay do you
understand the persan Army had won the
war and as salamis they lost the war
okay now the problem is when now that
the Virgin Navy has been
destroyed supply lines are in trouble
okay you understand because Greek is
Greece is very poor Greece is a very
poor Nation you cannot resupply yourself
in Greece how do you feel what half half
million people well you need to bring in
supplies from Persia but now your Navy
has been destroyed so now King Xerxes
freaks out and he goes home he's like
you know what I burn down Athens that's
good enough for me okay and he leaves
his cousin General Mardis to fight the
um Greeks okay and at this point
mardones could have chosen to not fight
the
Greeks right because because Athens has
been destroyed and Sparta is still under
threat so all mardones had to do was he
was in thieves okay he was in thieves
all he had to do was stay in thieves and
wait out the war okay this is what we
call a war of attrition where you wait
out the other enemy because the other
enemy has basically less resources than
you okay does that make sense again
really easy for the person to win but um
madonas chose to fight the Greeks at the
Battle of
ptia and here it was about equal forces
100,000 Greeks versus 100,000 Persians
and the Greeks destroyed the Persians
the Persians lost five times more men
than the uh Greeks okay and King uh
General Mardon was killed in this battle
so this war that the Persians should
have won very easily the Persians uh
lost and were completely destroyed okay
does that make
sense okay any questions so far about
the Persian
Invasion okay and because of this
war Greece now became extremely wealthy
the reason why is Persia is forced to
retreat from Asia Minor and the Greeks
were able to capture a lot of treasure
okay now um after this Persia switches
strategies okay Persia never again
invades Greece because they think this
is stupid to invade Greece okay but the
Greeks don't know this the Greeks think
okay the Persians will come back at any
point okay so the Athenians
say let's take the battle to Persia and
what do the Spartans say
say no we're going to go home and that's
it okay so to to battle against the
Persians theth create something called
The daan League the Delan league is a
defensive alliance between Athens and
these colonies and islands in the agian
the idea is if the Persians come back we
will Master forces and fight the
Persians at Sea the problem is that only
Athens had a Navy everyone else we have
a Navy so everyone else is like we don't
have a Navy but we'll contribute money
okay and they agreed that this money
this treasury would be could be only be
used against Persia if Persia invades
okay so they put all this money on a
place called delos okay an island called
delos that's why it's called the Delan
league right does that make sense so
basically Athens would put up a navy and
everyone else would put up money and
this
money um this treasury of the dlan
league can only be used in a war against
Persia okay does that make sense okay so
while this is
happening Athens is the rising power in
this world and in
461 BCE a new political leader called
per
comes into power and as you should know
from your research paricles is
considered um the father of Athenian
democracy he is the one who spreads
democracy throughout
Athens and historians today
worship U Pericles okay Pericles is
considered one of the greatest leaders
ever in Western in Western history okay
um I'll talk more about Pericles and
democracy in future classes okay but I
want to show you that Pericles was first
and foremost a politician who was
concerned about amassing and keeping
power does that make sense so he did a
lot of Wonder wonderful things for uh
Athens but I want to show you these
things that he did even though they
seemed great they really were about him
amassing power for himself
okay so um the first thing he did was he
spread democracy to everyone okay he
basically gave every citizen the right
to vote and you're like okay that's
great direct democracy Athens creates
democracy this is great right but the
reason why he did that was to change the
balance of power in Athens so he
basically represent the lower nobility
versus the upper nobility right usually
upper nobility has more power because it
has more money okay it has more Prestige
so the way for the lower nobility to
defeat the no the upper nobility is by
aligning itself with the people
okay doesn't make sense you do that by
giving people the right to vote and so
by doing this Pericles basically made
himself king of Athens does that make
sense in fact he stayed in power from
461 to
429 okay doesn't make sense all right
and to please the people even more he
basically made corruption official what
he did that was very important was he
basically took the money from delos and
brought it to Athens basically perally
said to the Delan League you know what
this money in delos it's a lot of money
I'm afraid that the person come and
steal it so let's take it to Athens okay
when he brought to Athens the next thing
he did was he spent all of it okay he
built a lot of really impressive
buildings including something called the
parnon um the paron is this Great temple
to Athena which is a patron goddess of
Athens they made uh the Athenian statue
out of gold okay they spent B millions
and billions of dollars on this Temple
the reason why is when you do that right
you give people
jobs and you give uh people who support
you money okay so this is basically
official
corruption now there are people in the
upper nobility who thought what Peres
was doing was terrible for Athens and
basically uh in meetings they want to
ostracize Pericles right they want to
they they accuse paricles of Corruption
of basically bribing the city of Athens
and they said you are corrupting our
morals okay you are hurting our
democracy therefore we want to ostracize
you and there was this vote against
Pericles and what happens you guys
know the people voted to Exile Pericles
opponents okay those who criticized
Pericles were now exiled from a
therefore Peres no longer has any
political opponents and per can do
whatever he wants and so the two big
Innovations of Pericles is democracy
okay right let's give people the right
to vote and let's give people more money
okay but also
Empire the reason why is after Perle
basically stole the money from the daan
league the allly we're obviously angry
right you store money so we are out of
this league empirically said well if you
leave our league we're going to come and
invade you so Athens start this
expansionist campaign in order to
maintain its Empire so the Dalian League
basically became the Athenian Empire and
now Athens got basically 20% of its
revenue from its allies okay
doesn't make sense so that's that's what
Pericles was doing he was promoting
democracy in order to make sure people
voted for him he was Pro promoting
Empire in order to maintain the easy
money flow into Athens Empire is
important because
remember um Athens has a culture of
udonia so Empire makes the rich
extremely wealthy you understand Empire
makes everyone rich but it makes the
wealthy even more
so and so the lower nobility okay the
lower nobility became very jealous and
so the way to we resolve this issue is
the low nobility could choose to uh
invade other places okay and if they win
they could make a lot of money money for
themselves so one place they chose to
invade was um Egypt but that failed okay
so throughout this time you had a lot of
Athenian Expeditions throughout the
world
in in looking to conquer a new territory
and sometimes they succeeded but some
but a lot of times they failed as well
okay does that make sense all right
so as Athens is expanding and becoming
much wealthier other Greek uh colonies
other Greek polies start to get angry at
Athens okay an Athens is basically the
big bully they were afraid of Persia
before but Persia didn't really bother
the Greeks whereas Athens um was a big
bully they wanted to control all of
Greece okay they basically were a mafia
organization that
um was forcing these islands in the agen
C to pay tribute to Athens they were
trying to take more more territory from
other Greek Poes so in
431 the Greek puses United around Sparta
and start started something called the P
pelian War okay and historic
what most historians will tell you is
this war was started because Sparta was
afraid of an emerging Athens okay Sparta
was the hedgemon sparta was was most
dominant power uh in Greece at that time
and now that Athens was Rising Sparta
felt threatened by Athens and therefore
declared war on Athens um that's not
true okay that's not the reason the
reason why is because Athens was an
Empire and they was going around and
bullying everyone and so you didn't have
a choice in the matter you got either
fight Athens now or wait for Athens to
invade you okay so it was because Athens
was a
imperial
power and so other nations had to other
Greek poets had no choice but to stand
against um Athens okay and Athens was an
imperial power because of its theory of
udonia okay so the Great irony here and
you will see this pattern um repeat
itself throughout history is the thing
the culture that allows a nation to rise
okay in this yonia will also cause it to
decline does it make sense okay because
it's because of the pelian war which
lasts from about
431 BC to 404 BCE 27 years that Athens
loses its Empire okay
so the culture udonia that causes Athens
to rise will ultimately lead to its
decline as well all right so are you
guys clear so
far please let me know if this is clear
to you if you have any questions before
before I
continue okay
so even though Sparta and Athens are now
at war with each other um this war again
should have been pretty easy won by
Athens why what can Athens do D do to
destroy
Sparta do you guys
know what can Athens do really easy they
destroy
Sparta helot right the Athenians have
ships they can choose to do what the
Persians should have done but they they
didn't do which is to basically take its
Navy land its Navy on the coast and
support the hellot in a rebellion okay
if that would have happened Sparta would
have been destroyed very quickly The
Atheist didn't do that right do you
understand theth didn't do that now
Sparta to counter this threat against
Athens what should it have done to
counter this threat against um from um
Athens exactly thank you okay its only
option in this scenario is to fre the
hots and say the hots if you fight for
us against
Athenians we will give you your Liberty
okay and the helot would have been yeah
let's go fight for the for for for the
Spartans okay so Sparta would have
increased his army 10 times and it could
have
destroyed Athens Sparta didn't do this
either okay you understand so from a
military strategy perspective the way
the pelian war didn't make any sense the
only way to
understand what happened is to
understand that the very basis of
conflict in society is between the upper
nobility and the lower nobility okay do
you understand the upper nobility is
only interested in maintaining the
status quo they're very conservative
they don't like Wars because you could
lose Wars and also because if you win
Wars you have people who are now richer
than you are okay do you understand so
nobility is very conservative in both
Athens and Sparta the L
nobility can only become upper nobility
through war or revolution okay so
they're always looking to upset the
status quo so even though this war is
going on internally there's still
conflict between the upper nobility and
the lower nobility okay and that's why
you look at the palpan war a lot of the
military strategy doesn't make any sense
because Sparta isn't really trying to
win a war against Athens Sparta is
trying to maintain the status quo in
Sparta okay Athens is not really trying
to win a war against Sparta Athens is
trying to main maintain the status quo
within Athens all right an example
is Pericles the war starts in 431 BC and
a lot of people are saying Pericles hey
let's go invade Sparta and what pericle
says instead is oh no no no the Spartans
are the greatest warriors in the world
we have no chance against Sparta so what
we'll do
is we have these
walls okay we have these walls we'll
we'll hide behind our walls and let our
Navy protect us in the sea okay that was
the defensive strategy of
paricles and so what the spars could do
was they could come to Atta
and destroy all the farmland and the
Athenians could only watch as the
Spartans destroy the Farmland this was
this was a disaster for the Athenians
because if you think about it over time
the Spartans could starve out the
Athenians right the other problem is you
have too many people in one place what
happens you have too many people living
in in a city what happens usually
disease right disease so because of the
over population in Athens they had the
plague which killed
onethird of the Athenian population okay
you understand onethird of the Athenian
population if the Athenians went to war
against
Sparta um and they lost they would have
at Lo at most lost about 10% of of the
population okay but because they chose
not to fight and hide behind the walls
not only did they lose their Farmland
but they lost a third of their
population including Pericles who died
because of the plague Pericles died as
well as his two sons
okay doesn't make sense right so again
the strategy makes no sense if you think
of from a military perspective it only
makes sense if you
understand there's a internal conflict
in Athens between the upper nobility and
the low lower nobility ility okay Peres
represents the upper nobility he wants
to maintain the status quo there's a war
going on but he doesn't really want to
fight this war okay he just he just
wants to wait it out because he does not
want to change the status quo does that
make sense so after um Pericles dies the
low nobility become ascendant okay and
because of this war they proposed an
aggressive strategy against the Spartans
okay basically it's like let's go attack
um the
Spartans and caused a revolution in
Sparta okay and this was the um this was
proposed by
Cleon who after um Pericles died became
uh basically the de facto leader of
Athens and he was considered a demagogue
okay if you look at the
history um everyone says bad things
about this guy okay but really what he
is he's l nobility who's trying to
achieve udonia okay and he's basically
like f pleas okay all right and he's a
great military strategist as well so
Cleon proposes this aggressive strategy
against Sparta and guess what happens
Athens is now destroying
Sparta okay now Sparta is under under a
lot of pressure it's losing the war so
now what sp sp um what spart does is it
picks a new general
brassus and says to brassus listen we're
losing a war what can we do so
bradus um goes
north and he starts to win these
victories against Athens and his policy
is this listen um we need to change our
social structure in order to win against
Athens so so what he does is he tell the
hot if you fight for me I'm gonna give
you your freedom and so so a lot of Hots
fight for bradus and brassus wins a lot
of
wars and this is and and how how do the
Spartans feel about
this brasses who's a Spartan is now
winning wars against Athens and so how
do the Spartans feel about
this are they happy about
this no they're really unhappy about
this okay because it's changing their
social
structure you understand they don't want
this crap they want the hots to be
slaves they don't want the hots to be
free citizens who helps them win Wars
okay so what ultimately happens is even
though Cleon and bradus have both prop
both strategies that allow Athens and
Spar to win the war ultimately what
happens is Cleon and brassus get into a
battle with each other and they both
died in this battle that's extremely
convenient guys okay that's really
really convenient so I'd be very
surprised if they actually did both die
in battle my guess is what happened is
they were both assassinated during the
battle against each other does that make
sense because
ultimately um both were the bigger
threats to the social structure of
Spartan and Athens than losing the war
itself does that make sense
guys
okay any questions so far
okay doesn't make sense okay okay so um
now so this war keeps on going and then
what happens is the Persia gets involved
and gives Sparta a Navy basically Persia
gives Sparta a blank check and because
Sparta is so conservative and insular it
doesn't really know how
to um how a Navy okay it doesn't know
how to fight with a navy in fact Sparta
is militarily like in terms of strategy
it's actually very weak okay if it's
like Spartan Soldiers by themselves are
very strong but in terms of like overall
milit military strategy Sparta because
it's so conserva insular it's very weak
against it's very weak compared with
Athens but Persia has a lot of money and
Persia is bankrolling Sparta okay and
eventually Persia says to Sparta hey
guys what are you try a new strategy the
strategy is this if a general is winning
against the Athenians promote the guy
okay and you're like okay well that
makes total sense the Spartans didn't do
that okay the Spartans were not
concerned about winning the war they
were concerned about maintaining their
social order do you understand there's a
social hierarchy in Sparta that's what's
important not with in the war and then
there was this Spartan Commander L
sander and he was really the only
Spartan who knew how to win Naval
battles the problem with lender was he
was a half
citizen which meant that his
his his father was a Spartan but not the
mother you understand only if both your
parents are citizens are you allowed to
be a citizen so lend was really looked
up looked down upon in Sparta but he
could win Naval battles so he wasn't
promoted the Persians
said to the spans listen this is stupid
okay lenter is a great Commander you
have to promote him the spans didn't
really have a choice in the matter and
so lender after he was promoted
single-handedly won the war against
Athens he laid SI to Athens in 404
BCE and
then um Athens had no choice but to
surrender because they were out of food
okay does that make sense
now for 27 for 27 years Sparta and
Athens were at war with each other they
were killing each
other now Athens had finally been
defeated so what do you think should
should happen
now what should be what should happen to
Athens
now okay the answer is nothing happened
to Athens okay usually if you lose the
war in this world what happens is they
come and kill all the men and enslave
all the woman and that's what the
Persians wanted okay that's what that's
what the other Greek cities wanted to
happen to Athens the Spartans didn't do
anything to Athens they left Athens
alone okay and there are many different
explanations for this one explanation is
Sparta wanted to maintain a balance of
power in the Greek World okay if they
destroyed Athens then Persia could come
back and Destroy Sparta okay um
um but another explanation is well guess
what guys the upper nobility of Sparta
and the upper nobility of
Athens they're good friends with each
other okay do you understand rich people
tend to marry each other they T to be
good friends of each other okay so
Athens and
Sparta weren't really enemies do you
understand they to fight this war
because of the internal pressures from
the no l low nobility but because this
war is killing off so much low so much
lower nobility it maintain a status quo
does that make
sense all
right you guys understand so far any
questions all right so I'm going to
conclude with evidence for this Theory
okay so uh what what I just said like
war is really about um killing off
internal descent not really about
beating another enemy that's very
controversial okay so I will give you
some evidence for this Theory and it's
called rat
Utopia so in in the 19 um 60s and 70s
there was an American researcher
American scientist his name is James B
kahun okay and he was interested in the
question what would it be like for
humans to live in a world of abundance
what would it mean for humans to live in
a world where everything was perfect
where you didn't have to fight for food
where food was just given to you okay a
Utopia what what would it be like well
he couldn't really experiment on humans
so he decided to experiment on rats
instead okay so he built this universe
okay basically this big house and food
was plentiful for rats the food the
water was plentiful for rats so rats can
just play all day okay now I'm not sure
if you know about anything about rats
but the thing about animals and this is
a very important idea is that animals
live in a
heavily
ritualized and
rules based World it doesn't make sense
guys we think of animals as chaotic no
no no if you actually study their
societies ants monkeys rats they live in
an extremely rule based heavily
ritualized World okay so let me let me
give you an example of this so uh rats
when they meet with each other what
happens is
this um a female rat is interested in
having sex okay so she's going out and
then and then a male rat spots this he
sees the female rat in heat so what he
does is he gets on a he gets on a mount
okay where she can see him and he starts
to dance
okay he starts to dance and the female
rat becomes interested and he sees she's
interested so he comes down and they
start chasing each other okay they're
having fun together and and then what
she does is she runs home and hides her
hides herself in her burel the M rat
just stands outside and waits for her to
come out after some time she comes up
and they run again run together again
and then she runs back again they do
this many many times until finally she
lets him catch him and then they have
sex okay and then and then after they
have sex they have children and they
start a family together okay does that
make sense okay that's how rats usually
behave when they they often like to play
with each other and they fight but it's
very playful okay so there's lots of
rules there's lots of rituals in this
rat
Society but that's out in nature in the
world of James B Hoon he creates rat
Utopia okay where everyone has enough to
eat and at some point the society breaks
down okay these these rituals these
rules all break down what happens is
male rats when they start fighting each
other they become very violent they're
no they're no longer playing they're
actually trying to kill each other and
some actually die okay and this like
mating ritual it breaks down
so the male rats don't even try to dance
okay they're not dancing they just see a
a female and they rape
her okay and it's like gang rape it's
not one male it's like lots of males
raping her these gangs of rats they try
to break into burls homes and try to
rape the wife okay the mother and at
first the husband is fighting off these
other rats right but eventually what
happens is he gets tired
and he just runs away okay he just AB
bands the family now the female rat is
responsible for fighting off now the
other rats but she becomes so
traumatized she starts to beat everyone
up including her own children so she
kicks her children out of the house it
is a complete social breakdown and after
a few more months of this crap the
entire colony of rats dies the entire
Society collapses does that make sense
all right this so this is what we call
Utopia it's been done many times and
each time they do this this happens at
some point the society will
collapse okay and this makes no sense to
us everyone has enough food to eat
everyone should be happy okay why does
why does society
collapse okay so there are different
explanations for this um James boun his
argument is if there's too much food
there's overpopulation there's over
overpopulation then that creates
conflict
then the conflict causes the rules to
collapse okay the problem though with
this theory is the colony never became
overpopulated okay there was space for
everyone but at some point everyone
started to fight each other all right so
this is my theory and this and this goes
back to the P pelian War it has to do
with the idea of
status so if in a world of abundance in
a world of wealth who benefits the most
it's the elderly old people
okay old people can live a lot longer in
a society that is wealthy and abundant
an abundant okay doesn't make
sense
okay but then what happens is the status
becomes locked in which prevents younger
rats younger people from ascending into
power and Status does that make sense
okay so the idea is the metaphor is
these rats are online okay I'm I'm
waiting for to climb the mountain okay
this is the mountain
top you're waiting and waiting to climb
the mountain and evence moving along
it's slow but you're still moving along
okay and eventually you will reach the
mountain top which is where you want to
be
but let just say for whatever reason the
line stops moving okay everyone's stuck
in place well then you get very anxious
you get very stressed out you get very
agitated you're like when is it my turn
and it's never going to come because the
people at the top won't
leave okay so what do you do well you
start kicking the people behind you
right you start fighting with with with
with with each other you
understand that's this is what we call
rat Utopia in a world of abundance in a
world of extreme wealth old people do
not
die if they do not die it is impossible
for young people to ascend into power
and
status and so they have all these
energies and because they cannot reach
their potential they become violent and
start attacking each other okay so
that's R Utopia that's what rats do but
if you look at the P War and what
happened between Athens and Sparta it's
really no different okay it's really no
different they were killing each other
for no reason extreme violence which led
to nothing okay 431 BCE the political
world was no different from 404 BC the
only difference is a lot of young people
died
okay and Wars against each
other so that's my argument to
you if societies become too
wealthy you have a problem of rat
Utopia okay if rat
Utopia societies will then engage
in wars that will lead eventually to its
collapse that's what happened to
Athens does that make sense
guys all right any questions about
thises does it make sense to you guys
all right any
questions
yeah okay
so um the question is in the r Utopia
why do the mothers want to start
attacking the kids okay
um okay so this is actually a
complicated question the answer is this
humans are different from rats okay so
humans have the ability to reason and to
uh adapt to new circumstances okay does
that make sense rats don't these there
are these rules in place okay and if
these rules are broken then the rats
don't know how to adapt so if you're a
rat mother you have a husband okay your
understanding is
the husband will protect you from
strangers okay your also your
understanding is if some is if someone
is violent towards you you to be violent
against that person okay so in a
situation where the husband leaves the
husband runs away or or his dead the
mother does not understand this New
Order
anymore so the mother becomes the word
we use is traumatized if you're
traumatized you can no longer reason
okay
you're so focused on protecting yourself
you attack everything and everyone
including your own
children does that make
sense yeah this is experiment because
obviously this would not happen in real
life okay there's no way the rats get
free food in real life so they have this
experiment where the experimenters gave
the rats free food every day and this is
what happened
no no so the experiment is the rats were
left by themselves okay the rats could
do whatever they wanted the only thing
the expers did was feed them every day
okay if you do that if there's abundance
and there's wealth there then you have
complete social
collapse
okay um okay okay all right so okay all
you need to understand is this
okay the entire Society collapses okay
how it collapses can be different from
family to family but the entire
cyclopsis everyone dies at the end okay
do you understand okay okay any more
questions any more questions
so I I know this is a lot to take in
okay this is very confusing and this is
very
hard uh but it's okay just ask any
questions or points where you want me to
clarify okay so next class we will do
Greek Theater and then after that we'll
do Greek philosophy which includes
Playdoh um socres aoso okay